I met Charlie Sheen so that was pretty
wild I worked on this thing called
typical Rick which is a Comedy Central
series with Nick Swardson
and Simon Rex and it was season two of
that and had a small part on there and I
walk over to wardrobe on the set and
Charlie Sheen is sitting there the big
dog himself you know mr. Tigers blood
HIV
you know the Superman
he was smoking a cigarette and so I got
me a cigarette and we started chatting
and just sharing the breeze and just
just throwing ideas around and I had
this shirt on that had a picture of uh
Michael Landon on it and everybody knows
him a big Michael Landon fan and Charlie
asked me about the shirt and I told him
about my fans ship and then he said that
um that one time he was at here that he
was escaping out of a rehab facility and
that one of Michael Landon's sons him
one of Michael Landon's children was in
the facility and as he was leaving he
saw the door open to the room of Michael
Landon's son and he asked him if he
wanted to go party with him and that
they left out and party for the weekend
so that was pretty cool man and he
looked I mean he was really captivating
great energy super sweet guy I mean just
honestly nicest could be and he looked
like he'd been at Spring Break for about
30 years in Cancun and and it was just
cool man it was interesting to just kind
of chat with him and just shoot the
breeze what else did we talk about that
was it man that was it dude and I'll
tell you this they had a couple ladies
there on set and I think any lady would
have left with him man I mean the dude
he just got that I don't know he's got
that he just had the charisma man that
chatty smih and so that was it so that
was part of an interesting part of the
weekend was just getting a bump in new
uh mr. Charlie Sheen himself thank you
guys for checking out this clip and if
you want to see another clip and you can
look at this clip or this clip either
one of these so did you pick one or he's
still just watching me do this because
it's alarming